en este vídeo quiero demostrarte que el
producto o la multiplicación de un
racional de un rayo
esto por un irracional por un irracional
irracional esto nos da un número
irracional
y
y ojo estoy diciendo que estoy tomándome
esta multiplicación del racional por
este irracional y nos da un irracional
si este racional es distinto de 0 porque
si fuera 0 0 por lo que sea es 0 y me
daría un número racional ok y para
llegar a esto que parece ser que tiene
todo el sentido lógico del mundo voy a
ocupar una demostración por
contradicción es decir voy a suponer que
no llegamos a un número racional y vamos
a llegar a una contradicción y si no
llegamos a un número racional
entonces eso quiere decir que vamos a
llegar a un número racional así que
bueno para tener la demostración por
contradicción lo que voy a hacer es
primero suponer vamos a ponerlo aquí voy
a suponer a suponer lo contrario suponer
suponer que la multiplicación de un
racional racional
por un irracional por un irracional
irracional como queremos llegar a una
contradicción entonces voy a suponer lo
contrario voy a suponer que nos lleva a
un número racional nos lleva a un número
relacional ahora si veo que esto no
tiene sentido si llevo una contradicción
entonces no me quedaría de otra la
multiplicación de un racional por un
irracional
me daría un irracional bueno para esto
que te parece si este racional el del
principio le ponemos un nombre a este de
aquí lo voy a ver como a / b
ok a / b lo voy a multiplicar por 1 muy
racional y como un número nacional es
muy pero muy pero muy largo lo voy a
denotar con x ok mi número racional este
nuevo y racional le voy a llamar x ok
y esto nos tiene que dar un número
nacional eso quiere decir que esto es lo
mismo lo mismo que un número racional
aunque le voy a poner el nombre de m / m
de m entre el ok y estamos suponiendo
que esto es cierto pero bueno si esto es
cierto entonces podemos despejar la x y
para despejar a equis qué te parece si
multiplico todo tanto el lado izquierdo
como el lado derecho esta igualdad por b
entre a por b entre am y este lado
también por b entre a por b entre a de
tal manera que éste se va a cancelar con
este esto se va a cancelar con este y
del lado izquierdo solamente me queda mi
x mil número irracional x va a ser igual
y del lado derecho me queda m / n por b
/ am ahora date cuenta que me entrené
por b / am es exactamente lo mismo por
propiedades de multiplicación de los
números racionales que m por ver que m
esto dividido entre n por a entre n por
a déjame cambiar el color por a ok ahora
date cuenta de lo siguiente aquí pasa
algo muy pero muy feo yo tengo m por b
lo puedes un número entero en el polar
es un número entero porque son
multiplicando 2 unos racionales y date
cuenta que el mejor de entre n por am es
un número racional este de aquí es de
aquí déjame ponerlo con este color
este de aquí es un número racional
porque tengo racional porque tengo la
proporción de dos números enteros pero x
habíamos dicho que era un número
completamente irracional de hecho es
justo como nos tomamos a x como un
número racional
por lo tanto estoy diciendo que x
debería ser debería
se ser racional racional y justo aquí es
cuando llego a la contradicción x no
puede ser racional e irracional al mismo
tiempo esto no tiene sentido o es
racional o es irracional por lo tanto
aquí está la contradicción yo había
supuesto que x es irracional y llego a
que debe ser racional y eso no tiene
sentido x no puede ser racional y
racional y entonces llegue a esta
contradicción porque empezamos
suponiendo que racional por irracional
es un número racional y llegamos a que
esto no puede ser cierto
por lo tanto justo en este momento estoy
probando lo que quería probar acá arriba
que un racional por una irracional me
debe de dar forzosamente un número
irracional y está de lujo ya llegué
justo a lo que quería para que no
lleguemos a una contradicción
forzosamente un racional por un
irracional me debe de dar un irracional